Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
(Mann) Jetzt beginnt
die Skiweltmeisterschaft von 1987.
* Majestätische, triumphale Musik *
(Mann) Der Schweizer Skirennsport
war am letzten Januartag 1987
auf seinem
absoluten Höhepunkt angelangt.
(Mann) In Crans-Montana
ist alles bereit.
1'250 Presseleute sind akkreditiert.
27 Fernsehsender berichten über
dieses aussergewöhnliche Ereignis.
* Majestätische, triumphale Musik *
(Mann) Seit 1970 war ich
bei Weltmeisterschaften mit dabei.
Nicht viele davon
wurden so gefeiert wie diese.
(Mann) Es war eine grosse Festhütte.
Hätte Crans-Montana ein Dach gehabt,
wäre es die grösste Festhütte
der Welt gewesen.
(Mann) Es war
eine fantastische Stimmung -
im Ort selbst und an der Piste.
Sensationell.
(Mann) Man wusste, dass das
Schweizer Team sehr stark war.
So war zumindest der Stand
nach der WM in Bormio,
wo die Schweiz einen wahren
Medaillenregen erlebt hatte.
(Mann) Gaspoz, Zurbriggen,
Hess, Figini, Walliser.
(Mann) Schon im Vorfeld
hatten sie Rennen gewonnen.
Österreich und Italien konnten
die Schweizer nicht schlagen.
(Mann) Die Schweizerinnen
gewannen alle Disziplinen.
(Mann) In diesen Zeiten
fragte man sich am Morgen nicht,
wer heute das Rennen gewinnen würde,
sondern welche Schweizer
gewinnen würden.
* Eindringlicher Jingle *
Ich erkläre die Alpine Skiweltmeis-
terschaft von 1987 in Crans-Montana
offiziell für eröffnet.
(Mann) Hier auf der Piste Nationale
werden am 31. Januar
und am 1. Februar
die beiden Abfahrten
der Männer und Frauen stattfinden.
Auf dieser Piste
wird Michela Figini am Sonntag
ihren vor zwei Jahren errungenen
WM-Titel verteidigen.
Figini war eine Sportlerin
mit überdurchschnittlichen
Fähigkeiten.
(Mann) Michela Figini, die im April
gerade mal 16 wird, war grossartig.
Schon im Alter von 15 Jahren stellte
die Schule sie vor die Entscheidung:
"Vom Skirennsport
bist du noch weit entfernt."
"Gib die Skirennen erst einmal auf
und geh zur Schule,
sonst brauchst du
gar nicht mehr zu kommen."
Darauf erwiderte sie: "Okay, danke,
tschüss. Ich gehe Ski fahren."
(Mann) Michela Figini, die am 7.
April bekanntlich 18 Jahre alt wird,
ist es gelungen,
ein Weltcuprennen zu dominieren.
Man wusste: Früher oder später
würde sie Weltmeisterin werden.
Sie befindet sich
in einem tollen Hoch,
und das unmittelbar
vor den Olympischen Spielen.
1:26:49.
Mit dem Sieg von Michela Figini
haben wir eine Premiere erlebt.
Ist Ihnen bewusst, dass Sie heute
Ihren ersten Weltcupsieg
errungen haben?
Ja, ich habe keine Fehler gemacht.
Das war wirklich eine super Abfahrt.
Rennen für Rennen verfolgte ich
Figinis Aufstieg aus nächster Nähe.
Ich sagte:
"Hör mal, ich habe eine Idee:
Wenn du in Sarajevo gewinnst,
schreibe ich ein Buch."
Und sie antwortete:
"Ah, si, comincia a scriv'" -
fang schon mal an zu schreiben.
(Mann) Michela Figini am Start.
49:05 - eine halbe Sekunde Vorsprung
für Michela Figini.
Die Zeit, die sie schlagen muss:
1:14:55.
Michela Figini ist ganz nah dran.
Im Ziel mit klarem Vorsprung:
1:13:36 für Michela Figini.
Goldmedaille: Olympiasiegerin
Michela Figini, Schweiz.
"Comincia a scriv'."
Eine andere hätte gesagt:
"Nein, nein, daran ist noch
gar nicht zu denken, man muss ..."
Fang schon mal an zu schreiben.
(Mann) Und jetzt: Abfahrts-
weltmeisterin Michela Figini.
Die grosse Favoritin
ist an der Reihe.
Das wird sicher
die Bestzeit für Michela.
Das ist die Bestzeit
mit unglaublichem Abstand.
Die Tessiner Fans
sind im Freudentaumel.
Sie ist ganz klar schneller.
Schauen Sie sich
ihre Riesenfreude an.
Die mehrfache Weltmeisterin
aus Prato in der Leventina
hat in den letzten Saisons alles
gewonnen, was es zu gewinnen gab.
Michi kam als Naturmädchen
in diesen Skizirkus.
Dort fühlte sie sich
eigentlich nie wohl.
* Lautes Stimmengewirr *
Sobald ich die Startschranke
passierte, war ich in meiner Welt.
Fantastisch.
Nach dem Rennen
war es immer etwas komplizierter.
Die Presseleute stellen eigentlich
immer die gleichen Fragen.
Am Donnerstag Siebte, gestern
Zweite, heute Erste. Zufrieden?
Sehr zufrieden.
Das grosse Problem ist,
dass jeder eine möglichst exklusive
Antwort haben will.
Wenn Sie sich einen Moment gedulden,
2 Min., das wäre noch besser.
Ich möchte,
dass meine Trainer mich hochheben.
* Stimmengewirr *
Nein, meine Trainer.
* Bedrückende Musik *
Zu einem anderen wichtigen Teil
deiner Arbeit:
der Beziehung zu den Journalisten.
Einer von ihnen schrieb einen
harschen Artikel: "Schade, Michela".
So etwas in einer bekannten Zeitung
zu lesen, hat dich sicher verletzt.
Ja, manche Dinge
kann man nicht vergessen.
Cos'è successo?
Man sagt einen Satz, und der
wird dann ganz anders ausgelegt.
Der Journalist
schreibt einen negativen Artikel,
ein anderer wärmt ihn wieder auf,
und am Ende wird
ein ganzer Berg Lügen daraus.
Das hat natürlich die ganze Abfolge
bei ihr verhärtet.
Sie zog sich in der Mannschaft
immer mehr zurück
und wurde dadurch immer isolierter.
Vielleicht hat sie nicht den
Bedürfnissen der Medien entsprochen.
Vermutlich,
weil sie keine Lust dazu hatte
oder nicht wollte.
Ausserdem hatte sie
in dieser Zeit eine Konkurrentin,
die in einem ganz anderen Verhältnis
zu den Medien stand.
Genau. Du meinst Maria Walliser.
(Keel) Maria war
das Golden Girl, eine Strahlefrau.
Man nannte sie
die hübscheste Skifahrerin.
Sie wusste das,
sie konnte es auskosten,
und sie konnte es auch präsentieren,
ohne dass es zu arrogant wirkte.
(Mann) Sie sind
eine öffentliche Figur.
Stört oder freut Sie das?
Man muss sich einfach
irgendwann entscheiden:
"Das ist jetzt mein Beruf,
mein Sport."
Ich habe mich dafür entschieden,
und darum gefällt es mir auch.
* Anfeuerungsrufe *
(Mann) Das wird
eine sehr gute Zeit für Maria.
Sie geht in Führung.
Neue Bestzeit!
Maria wollte
besser sein als die anderen.
Sie wusste schon, was sie wollte,
und sie gab alles dafür.
(Mann) Sie wollte nicht hübsch,
sondern schnell sein.
(Mann) C'était une saison excellente
pour la Saint-Galloise.
(Mann) Mit kaum 20 Jahren
ist Maria Walliser
nicht nur eine Ikone
des Schweizer Skisports,
sondern auch
die würdige Nachfolgerin
der Tessinerin Doris De Agostini,
der sie auf dem ersten Platz
des Abfahrtsweltcups
am Ende der Saison 1984
nachfolgen sollte.
Aber zuvor muss es
der schönen St. Gallerin gelingen,
nächste Woche an den Olympischen
Spielen in Sarajevo zu glänzen,
wo sie
die überragende Favoritin ist.
(Mann) Und Maria Walliser am Start.
22:20, die beste Zwischenzeit
für Maria Walliser.
Das wird knapp.
Nein, Maria Walliser auf Platz 2,
5/100 Sek. hinter Figini.
Natürlich, das ist im ersten Moment
eine masslose Enttäuschung.
Ich hatte schon eine Vergangenheit,
hatte schon
meine ersten Rennen gewonnen.
Ich musste schon erklären,
warum ich nicht gewonnen hatte,
sondern nur Zweite wurde.
Das ist ein grosser Unterschied.
Bei dieser Abfahrt war Maria Walliser
ohne Zweifel die grosse Favoritin
für die Goldmedaille.
Doch leider
kam die hübsche St. Gallerin,
vielleicht aufgrund
der psychischen Belastung,
einige Male ganz leicht
von der Ideallinie ab,
und beim Zieleinlauf
war das Ergebnis ein harter Schlag.
Ich bin dieses Jahr allgemein
sicher mit anderen Erwartungen
zur Weltmeisterschaft angerückt.
Aber das sind einfach Rennen,
die an einem Tag stattfinden.
An diesem Tag
zeigen Gewisse ihre Stärke,
und die anderen
müssen das akzeptieren.
Ich nahm auch die Weltcupsaison
an sich immer sehr ernst.
Ich konzentrierte mich nicht nur
auf Grossveranstaltungen.
In der Bildmitte: Maria Walliser,
die den Gesamtweltcup gewinnt.
Diese Kugel
bedeutete mir eigentlich fast mehr.
Sie zeichnete einfach aus,
dass man über eine ganze Saison
konstant
seine Leistung erbracht hatte.
* Spannende Musik *
In Kürze beginnt die Alpine Ski-
weltmeisterschaft in Crans-Montana.
Im Wallis erwartet man
bei strahlendem Sonnenschein
gleich mehrere Wunder
von der goldenen Generation
Zurbriggen, Figini, Müller,
Walliser und Gaspoz,
die nun offensichtlich
reif dafür sind.
Aber man sollte nicht
der Euphorie verfallen,
denn manches deutet darauf hin,
dass das Gleichgewicht dieses
legendären Kaders zerbrechlich ist.
In unserer Mannschaft
gibt es mehrere Persönlichkeiten.
In den letzten Jahren ist die Spitze
der Siegläuferinnen gross.
Ich glaube,
jede hat ihren individuellen Weg.
Beim Skifahren besteht
die Mannschaft aus Individuen.
Man tritt zwar gegen andere an,
kämpft aber für sich selbst
und gegen die Uhr.
Ich habe mich immer nur
auf mich selbst konzentriert.
Im Sport ist kein Platz
für Grosszügigkeit.
Im Sport geht es ums Überleben.
Jeder ist auf sich gestellt.
Marianne.
Nummer 2 hat Eder.
Wer will Nummer 3?
Für die Trainer war es nie leicht,
die Mädchen zu führen.
Sie waren grosse Rivalinnen.
Man hatte immer das Gefühl oder
Angst, dass es eskalieren könnte.
(Mann) Der Superstar der Schweizer
Mannschaft, Pirmin Zurbriggen,
ist am Flughafen Sitten gelandet,
wo ihn Dutzende Presseleute
und mehrere Hundert Fans empfingen.
In Crans-Montana wird Zurbriggen
mit Heimvorteil antreten -
in allen fünf Disziplinen.
Die ganze Schweiz erwartet
einen Medaillenregen von ihm.
Schöner könnte es
kurz vor der WM nicht sein.
Wir wollen keine Prognose hören,
aber Ihre Form scheint optimal.
Ja, die Form habe ich.
Ich habe bis jetzt viel erreicht,
was ich wollte.
(Als ich nach Crans-Montana ging,
stand ich stark unter Druck.)
(Ich hatte
ein eher schlechtes Gefühl.)
Ich konnte es nicht verstehen,
aber ich war irgendwie
etwas pessimistisch.
* Drängende, vibrierende Musik *
Zurbriggen, ein Allround-Champion,
hat eine Vorliebe
für die schnellen Disziplinen,
aber auch für die technischen,
z.B. Slalom.
Pirmin war ein Alleskönner. Er
gewann den Super-G und den Slalom.
Er hatte also das Zeug
zu einem perfekten Champion.
Wenn es in einer Disziplin
nicht so gut geht,
Kann ich mein Selbstvertrauen
in einer anderen wieder aufbauen,
in der es besser läuft.
Das ist ein Vorteil für mich.
(Mann) Ja, 2:00:98.
Fantastisch, Pirmin Zurbriggen!
Es war für mich eine Challenge,
eine Herausforderung,
wechseln zu können.
Für mich wäre es
fast langweilig gewesen,
nur Slalom
oder nur Riesenslalom zu machen.
Das wäre für mich
zu wenig Inspiration gewesen.
(Mann) Mit erst 21 Jahren ist
der Oberwalliser, Pirmin Zurbriggen,
schon Titelträger
in der Gesamtwertung des Weltcups.
(Mann) Der grosse Pirmin
mit einer Gesamtzeit von 1:36.02.
(Mann) Nachdem er heute morgen
den Spezialslalom
in Sestriere gewonnen hat,
kann er jetzt in jeder Disziplin
einen Sieg aufweisen -
ausser in der Abfahrt.
Denken Sie schon
an einen Sieg in der Abfahrt?
Ja, ich möchte
eine Abfahrt gewinnen.
Es ist ein grosses -
wie sagt man? - Ziel.
* Pulsierende, drängende Musik *
(Mann) Das Rennen
beginnt in wenigen Sekunden.
Und hier kommt Pirmin Zurbriggen.
Oh, er springt weit,
aber er ist absolut in der Zeit.
Das müsste eine gute Zwischenzeit
für Zurbriggen sein.
Ja, die Bestzeit!
Pirmin ist dabei, seinen ersten
Weltcupsieg in der Abfahrt zu holen.
Und da ist das Ziel.
Geschafft!
2:08:65 - 1,4 Sek. Vorsprung
für Pirmin Zurbriggen.
Wir waren völlig verblüfft,
dass er eine Abfahrt gewann.
Was sollte man von so einem Typen
mit Engelsgesicht halten,
der so ruhig und besonnen war?
Wie war es möglich,
dass er in Kitzbühel gewann,
wo man wirklich Mut braucht?
So ist es.
Ich fand mich in zwei Welten.
Einerseits
hatte es mit Gefahr zu tun ...
* Dumpfer Klang *
... andererseits mit Vertrauen.
(Mann) 133 km/h.
Man spürt förmlich, wie er kämpft.
Das stimmt.
Oft forderte ich das Risiko heraus.
Alle anderen dachten, ich spinne.
Pirmin an den Grenzen
seiner Möglichkeiten.
Ich fühlte mich - wow -
total sicher.
Ich lernte das zu einem grossen Teil
vom Glauben und Gebet
meiner Mutter und Grosseltern.
Ich nahm diesen Pott ganz einfach
und setzte ihn zum Sport.
(Mann) Der Walliser ist gestartet.
Für Pirmin Zurbriggen
steht jetzt alles auf dem Spiel.
Vorsicht beim Sprung.
Ein Hundertstel kann für
Pirmin Zurbriggen entscheidend sein.
Ja, 2:06:95!
* Applaus, Kuhglocken *
Seit dem Wochenende gibt es
sozusagen nur noch ein Thema:
den Triumph, aber leider auch die
Verletzung von Pirmin Zurbriggen.
In einer 30-minütigen Operation
wurde ihm am Sonntag ein Teil
des linken Innenmeniskus entfernt.
Heute
hat Pirmin Zurbriggen erfahren,
ob die WM in Bormio ein Wunschtraum
bleibt oder ob sein Comeback
wenigstens aus medizinischer Sicht
sichergestellt ist.
Am fünften Tag nach der Operation
ging ich joggen.
Ich ging 7 km joggen.
Als ich ins Spital zurückkam
und der Arzt mich sah, sagte er:
"Pirmin, du spinnst!"
Zehn Tage darauf
ging ich zum ersten Mal Ski fahren.
(Mann) Pirmin Zurbriggen
ist gestartet.
(Mann) Heute in Bormio
ist es Pirmin Zurbriggen gelungen,
nur drei Wochen
nach seiner Meniskusoperation
die WM-Abfahrt zu gewinnen.
Ein wahres Wunder.
(Mann)
Pirmin Zurbriggen ist Weltmeister.
Daran besteht kein Zweifel mehr.
Ich ging dort wieder ans Limit,
ohne mir bewusst Angst zu machen,
ohne vor irgendeiner Zukunft
Angst zu haben.
(Mann) Pirmin Zurbriggen, Svizzera.
Es ging so weit, dass manche
dachten, ich wäre gedopt gewesen.
Oder dass ich
ein Medikament bekommen hätte.
Das war alles nicht wahr.
Es war für alle
eine verwundernde Geschichte.
(Mann) Silbermedaille:
Peter Müller, Svizzera, Schweiz.
(Mann) Peter Müller fährt ins Ziel.
1:45:97 -
eine herausragende Leistung.
(Mann) Peter Müller,
den man gerne verachtete.
...58, und hier kommt Peter Müller.
(Mann) Als Unterländer
hat er es sicher auch schwerer,
Fans zu mobilisieren,
als Fahrer aus Skiorten,
die dann fast dem Dorf
oder sogar dem Kanton gehören.
Das spielt eine entscheidende Rolle.
Als Städter kommt man nur schwer
in die Skinationalmannschaft.
Für Peter Müller,
der keinen einfachen Charakter hat,
ist es doppelt schwer.
Als ich zum ersten Mal ankam, sagte
praktisch die ganze Mannschaft:
"Müller,
du magst ein lieber Kerl sein,
aber du kannst nicht Ski fahren
und hast bei uns nichts verloren."
"Du passt nicht zu uns."
Das war die Begrüssung.
Das war natürlich
nicht so freundlich.
Ich zog mich aber nicht zurück,
sondern sagte:
"Ihr seid drei Jahre in diesem Kader
und noch nicht weitergekommen."
Ihr seid Riesenwürste.
Peter Müller
ist auf jeden Fall sehr begabt
und hat einen
überaus starken Willen -
manchmal vielleicht
fast zu stark für ein Team.
Eines Tages kreuzte Müller
mit gebogenen Skistöcken auf.
Alle lachten darüber.
Tja, zwei Rennen später
hatten alle diese Stöcke.
(Mann) Peter Müller - ein Name, der
für Kraft und Schnelligkeit steht.
1977 stiess er zum A-Kader.
Seitdem
hat er es nicht mehr verlassen.
Vergangene Saison brachten ihn
der Sieg in Villars-sur-Ollon
und vier zweite Plätze
an die Spitze der Weltcup-Abfahrt.
Nach Russi und Collombin
ist er nun die Nummer 1
der Schweizer Nationalmannschaft.
Als ich in die Mannschaft kam,
gingen die Arrivierten am Nachmittag
bei Kaffee und Kuchen
das Leben geniessen.
Ich schaute am Nachmittag
3 oder 4 Std. lang Videos
und versuchte jene zu kopieren,
die schneller waren.
Er verbrachte unzählige Stunden
unten im Keller,
um Wege zu finden,
um noch schneller zu werden.
Alle sagten: "Du wirst alles,
nur kein Skifahrer."
"Du gewinnst nie ein Weltcuprennen."
Das gab mir vielleicht
die Motivation, zu kämpfen
und auch im Training mehr zu machen.
Es wäre klüger gewesen,
manche Dinge weniger zu machen.
(Mann)
Jetzt ist Peter Müller im Ziel.
Er ist Zweiter. 2:06:79.
(Mann) Peter Müller wurde gestern
an der Weltmeisterschaft in Bormio
erneut Zweiter,
nachdem er schon letztes Jahr
an Olympia Platz 2 belegt hatte.
Dabei konnte er in seiner Karriere
neun Weltcupabfahrten gewinnen.
Klebt an seinen Ski bei Grossanlässen
wirklich das Pech?
* Einzelner Jodelruf *
Leider fand Pitsch
gern allerlei Ausreden und meinte,
dass das Schicksal gegen ihn war.
Oben war stürmischer Wind,
und man sah nicht
von einem Tor zum nächsten.
Es kam noch Nebel auf.
Auf einigen Stücken ist es so weich,
dass man richtig einbricht.
Einmal sagte er:
"Ich habe Öl vom Pistenfahrzeug
unter die Ski bekommen -
das hat mich gebremst."
Nur ihn natürlich, sonst keinen.
Als ich ins Starttor fuhr,
wehten noch richtige Sturmböen.
Wegen seines weinerlichen Stimm-
ausdrucks war er nicht so beliebt.
Müller war eine Persönlichkeit.
Der Sport lebt von Persönlichkeiten.
Wer Peter Müller einmal gesehen hat,
dem geht er nicht mehr aus dem Sinn.
Er hat einen echten Charakterkopf.
Den vergisst man nicht.
* Langsamer Jodelakkord *
(Mann) Ich sagte ihm mal:
"Pitsch, du musst dich ändern."
Du musst dich anpassen.
Er sagte: "Willst du,
dass ich mich anpasse
oder dass ich schnell fahre?"
Da sagte ich:
"Für mich musst du schnell fahren."
(Mann) Wir sehen Joël Gaspoz
im zweiten Lauf.
Joël Gaspoz
wird das Unmögliche versuchen,
um diesen zweiten Platz zu halten.
Joël war für mich seit der Jugend
ein Phänomen.
Joël war für mich wie ...
ein Rennpferd.
Er konnte während des Trainings
Holldrio machen,
und wenn's im Rennen drauf ankam:
Bumm!
(Mann) Der Skifahrer aus Morgins
ist schnell - ein schöner Stil.
Er war ein Vollblutathlet.
Er konnte nicht dosieren.
Er ging immer ans absolute Limit.
(Mann) Oh, ja. Oh, das war schön.
Ein Künstler
mit ausserordentlichem Feingefühl.
Wenn der Künstler am Werk war
und aus dem Vollen schöpfen konnte,
malte er
die schönsten Bilder für uns.
Mein erstes WM-Rennen fuhr ich schon
mit fünfzehneinhalb Jahren.
Ich hatte mir nie in den Kopf
gesetzt, ein Champion zu werden.
Ich glaube, ich kam auf die Welt
und hatte gar keine andere Wahl.
(Mann) Heute Morgen im italienischen
Aprica errang Joël Gaspoz,
der junge Skifahrer aus Morgins, den
ersten Weltcupsieg seiner Karriere.
Auf eisglatter, festgefrorener Piste
erzielte er mehr als 2 Sek. Vorsprung
auf den Amerikaner Phil Mahre
und dem legendären Vertreter
dieser Disziplin, Ingemar Stenmark.
* Triumphale klassische Musik: "Le
nozze di Figaro" von W.A. Mozart *
In der Zeitung stand: "Joël Gaspoz,
der Mozart des Skisports".
So etwas lässt einen nicht kalt.
Ich stand zwar
nicht gern im Mittelpunkt,
aber ich freute mich sehr darüber.
(Mann) Was ist schwieriger, das
Skifahren oder das ganze Drumherum?
Halten Sie sich für
eine wichtige Persönlichkeit?
Ja, schon ein wenig. Aber für mich
spielt das keine Rolle.
Ich versuche einfach,
ganz normal zu sein.
Sie haben einen guten Ausgleich:
die Musik.
Ja, ich liebe Musik.
Sie tut mir gut.
Ohne Musik könnte ich
wahrscheinlich nicht leben.
* Piependes Startsignal *
(Mann) Hier kommt Joël Gaspoz,
der auf der Suche
nach sich selbst ist
und in dem
Zweifel aufzukommen scheinen.
Sein bestes Ergebnis ist hier
der 19. Platz im Spezialslalom.
Ein wenig enttäuschend diese Saison.
Er startet, und schon ist es vorbei.
Joël hat ganz offensichtlich
ein Problem.
Zwischen 20 und 23
machte ich schwierige Phasen durch.
Ich dachte nicht mehr ans Skifahren.
Ich war verliebt
und ging in die Rekrutenschule.
In gewisser Weise
lernte ich das Leben kennen.
Motiviert bin ich immer, aber viel-
leicht nicht immer zum Skifahren.
(Mann) Aber ist Gaspoz
auch mental ein Profi?
Genau da liegt unser Schwachpunkt:
die Einstellung im Training
und die Einstellung im Rennen -
aber v.a. im Training.
* Drängende, spannende Musik *
(Mann) Der Skirennfahrer aus Morgins
gehört wieder
zu den Besten im Skisport -
nicht nur in der Schweiz,
sondern weltweit.
Hoffen wir, dass ihm vier Jahre
nach seinem Sieg in Aprica
eine Wiederholung gelingt.
Ich denke, das klappt.
2:16:88 - ein sensationelles Ergebnis
für den Walliser,
der nie aufgegeben hat.
Als ich unten war, wusste ich, eines
Tages würde ich wieder oben sein.
Es dauerte viele Jahre,
bis ich wieder in Topform war.
Ich habe dieses Jahr
besser trainiert.
Jetzt habe ich wieder
die Aggressivität
und die Kondition
von früher erreicht.
Ich glaube,
das macht den Unterschied.
Ich bin sehr stolz darauf.
Der Weg nach oben ist hart,
aber wenn man fällt
und wieder aufstehen muss,
ist es noch härter.
(Mann) Ein beeindruckender Erfolg
für Joël Gaspoz aus Morgins.
Dank seines heutigen Siegs
im Riesenslalom in Lake Placid,
dem letzten Rennen der Saison,
holt er in letzter Minute
den Weltcup in dieser Disziplin -
mit einem winzigen Punkt Vorsprung
vor dem Schweden Stenmark.
Sie praktizieren Sophrologie.
Was bedeutet Ihnen
diese Entspannungstechnik?
Sie tat mir gut,
v.a. in sehr schwierigen Phasen.
Ich hatte von allem genug,
doch innerhalb weniger Wochen
konnte ich auf ein sehr hohes Niveau
zurückfinden.
(Mann) Applaus für Joël Gaspoz.
Auf mich wartete etwas ganz Grosses:
Crans-Montana.
(Mann) Wenn man
einen Weltcup gewonnen hat,
denkt man sicher auch
an den Weltmeistertitel.
Ja, hoffen kann man schon,
aber es sind Weltmeisterschaften.
Ein Rennen an einem Tag -
da kann alles passieren.
Der Druck war enorm.
Es war nicht auszuhalten.
* Dunkler Klang *
(Frau) Die WM in Crans-Montana
beginnt mit
der Kombination der Herren,
bei der am Ende der vielseitigste
Rennfahrer zum Sieger gekrönt wird.
In dieser Sparte stehen zwei Männer
seit mehreren Saisons
vor allen anderen:
der Walliser Pirmin Zurbriggen,
amtierender Weltmeister
in dieser Disziplin,
und der Luxemburger Marc Girardelli,
Gewinner
der letzten beiden Gesamtweltcups.
Ich hatte den Cup 1985 und
1986 gewonnen - zweimal vor Pirmin.
Pirmin war 1987
einfach unglaublich stark.
Es war die beste Saison
seiner Karriere.
Ich wusste, ich hatte
keine Chance auf den Weltcup.
Er war einfach zu stark.
(Mann) Jetzt ist Girardelli
an der Reihe,
der alles auf die WM
in Crans-Montana setzen wird.
Die einzige Chance auf einen
positiven Abschluss der Saison
war für mich,
eine Medaille zu gewinnen.
(Mann) Und jetzt Pirmin.
(Zurbriggen) Ich hatte
in den vorherigen Rennen
sehr viel Energie verbraucht.
Am Start war ich praktisch k. o.
(Mann) Er hat ein wenig Mühe,
den Rhythmus zu finden.
Im Ziel erreicht er mit seiner Zeit
nur Platz 10.
54:12 - er wirkt,
als laufe er auf dem Zahnfleisch.
Ich kam ins Ziel und hätte gar nicht
auf die Tafel sehen müssen.
Ich wusste genau:
Es war ein Scheisslauf.
In der Kombinationsabfahrt
muss Zurbriggen Girardelli
um fast 0,6 Sek. schlagen,
um sich diesen WM-Titel zu sichern,
den er nicht
seinen Rivalen überlassen will.
1:30:52 gegen 1:30:98,
und Zurbriggen
hat noch 3/10 Sek. aufzuholen.
Das wird reichen.
Oh, ein sehr langer Sprung.
Sehr gut gelandet.
1:52:90, und es würde reichen.
Ich bin nicht sicher,
ob er das schafft.
Nein, nein, er schafft es nicht.
Er ist Zweiter.
Er ist Zweiter in der Kombination.
Pirmin Zurbriggen
hat seinen WM-Titel verloren.
Ich sagte immer,
es sei mein grosses Glück,
mehrere Disziplinen zu haben.
Dieses Rennen
brauchte ich für das nächste Rennen.
Denn in dem Rennen merkte ich:
"Jetzt ist der Start gemacht."
"Jetzt kann's losgehen."
(Mann) Montana
hat sich in den letzten Tagen
von seiner strahlendsten Seite
präsentiert.
Doch gestern Abend brach
diese Schönwetterfront zusammen,
und es begann zu schneien.
(Mann) In Crans-Montana
herrscht trübes Wetter.
Die Wettkämpfe werden
seit 48 Std. immer wieder verschoben.
(Mann) Wird gestartet oder nicht?
Das ist die Frage,
die weltweit die Gemüter bewegt.
Alle warten gespannt
auf diesen Wettkampf.
In Crans-Montana wurde heute
die Kombinationsabfahrt der Damen
wegen des schlechten Wetters
abgesagt.
(Mann) Es war unmöglich. Keine Sicht.
(Mann) Um den Frust
noch zu verschlimmern,
sind die Hotels nicht ausgebucht
und auch in den Restaurants
herrscht wenig Betrieb.
Die Leute sitzen lieber
zu Hause im Warmen vor dem Fernseher.
Die Organisatoren hoffen,
dass am Wochenende,
an dem zwei Abfahrten
auf dem Programm stehen,
nicht nur das gute Wetter, sondern
auch das Publikum zurückkehrt.
* Dunkler Klang *
(Mann) Meine Damen und Herren,
guten Tag und herzlich willkommen
in Crans-Montana
zum wohl grössten Ereignis
der Alpinen Skiweltmeisterschaften:
der Herrenabfahrt.
Das Rennen wird vor Ort von
mehreren Zehntausend Fans verfolgt,
die sich schon vor Sonnenaufgang
aus Crans-Montana hierherbegeben
und um die ganze Piste Nationale
versammelt haben.
Das Bühne ist bereit.
Die Schweizer Herzen
sind gespalten zwischen Peter Müller,
dem Sieger der ersten
der beiden Abfahrten von Las Leñas,
und Pirmin Zurbriggen, der in 7 Min.
seinen Titel verteidigen wird.
Pirmin steht unter grossem Druck,
wenn man sich vor Augen führt,
dass wohl 60 % der Anwesenden
gekommen sind,
um ihn gewinnen zu sehen.
Ich war froh,
dass wir die drei Tage hatten.
Ich konnte mich erholen und
auf den grossen Moment vorbereiten.
(Mann) Volle Konzentration
bei Pirmin Zurbriggen.
(Mann) Und los geht es für Pirmin
mit viel Publikumsunterstützung.
Dieser extrem lange Schuss -
128 km/h für Zurbriggen.
31:81, kurz vor dem Cry d'Er,
wo er jetzt zum Sprung ansetzt.
Ein sehr schöner Sprung -
nicht zu lang, genau richtig.
Im Moment
läuft es fabelhaft für Zurbriggen.
Wird er alle schlagen?
Die Spannung ist immens.
59:09, also unter 1 Min.
an dieser Stelle,
wo gestern der Schnellste
1:01 schaffte.
Und in Kürze
wird Pirmin auf der Zielgeraden
von gigantischem Jubel empfangen.
Hören Sie sich das an!
* Lauter, vielstimmiger Jubel *
(Mann) Pirmin Zurbriggen, bejubelt
von vielen Tausend Zuschauern.
(Mann) 2:08:13.
Pirmin wird schwer zu schlagen sein.
Du spürst,
wie schnell du unterwegs bist.
Du weisst genau,
wo die kleinen Fehler sind.
Ich dachte,
es sei nicht schlecht gewesen,
aber ich hatte einen Fehler gemacht.
Ich wusste von einem Fehler,
und das war der letzte Sprung.
Ich hatte die Befürchtung,
dass es deswegen knapp werden würde.
Dass ich deswegen
2 oder 3/10 Sek. verloren hatte.
(Durchsage) Mit Startnummer 7:
Peter Müller, Schweiz.
(Mann) Und Peter Müller.
Peter ist eher ...
Er ist kein Mann der grossen Rennen.
Ich war am Start: "Fünf, vier ..."
Neben mir stand ein Walliser.
Er sagte mir
in seinem Walliserdeutsch:
"Ja, Pitsch,
heute wirst du Zweiter."
Ich dachte: "Da bist du
zu Hause an der WM,
und ein Schweizer wünscht dir,
dass du Zweiter wirst."
* Piepender Countdown *
(Mann) Nun ist Peter Müller
auf der Piste.
Auch er ist ein grosser Favorit.
Zweiter bei der Zwischenzeit,
2/100 Sek. hinter Zurbriggen.
Müller dürfte für Zurbriggen sicher
der gefährlichste Konkurrent sein.
Er schafft es nicht.
Er ist Zweiter mit 2:06:79.
Immer, wenn viel auf dem Spiel
stand, wurde er Zweiter.
Er wurde Zweiter,
Vierter, Zweiter, Dritter, Vierter.
Difficile?
- Oh, ça va.
Fast jedes Mal, wenn man sich
mit Kollegen oder der Presse trifft:
"Hol jetzt die Goldmedaille, hol die
Goldmedaille. Du bist der Beste."
In jeder Bar: "Pitsch,
wann gewinnst du endlich mal?"
Das gibt dir ... Einerseits
hilft es, aber es bremst auch.
(Mann) Silbermedaille:
Peter Müller, Svizzera, Schweiz.
(Zurbriggen) Pitsch war für mich
in der Abfahrt der stärkste Gegner.
Er war nicht immer aller Freund.
Er suchte gerne die Konfrontation.
Aber ich glaube,
Pitsch brauchte das genau so.
Er brauchte das als Motivation,
für die Überzeugung:
"So, heute, heute. Komme, was wolle,
heute will ich gewinnen."
(Mann) Seine Mission
für Crans-Montana: Gold holen.
* Eindringliche, spannende Musik *
(Mann) Peter Müller ...
... ist gestartet.
Er kommt zur Zwischenzeit.
Das wird sehr eng.
Allerdings hat er
einen kleinen Rückstand - 4/100 Sek.
(Mann) 4/100 Sek.,
das wird unheimlich spannend.
Jetzt hat Peter Müller
auf die vorherige Zwischenzeit
8/100 Sek. aufgeholt.
Jetzt sind es nur noch 5/100.
Es ist kaum auszuhalten.
Diese knappe Differenz!
5/100 Sek. Unterschied -
unfassbar.
Es wird unheimlich knapp.
111,2 km/h - er ist schneller,
springt noch etwas höher,
landet nicht ganz so sauber.
2:08:13 - das wird sehr knapp,
aber ich glaube, er schafft es.
Ja, 2:07:80!
Bestzeit für Peter Müller.
33/100 Sek. vor Pirmin Zurbriggen.
Pirmin Zurbriggen
hat seinen WM-Titel verloren
und Peter Müller
übernimmt die Führung.
Jetzt beginnt
die lange Zeit des Wartens.
Ich wusste, dass ich an der Cry d'Er
einen grossen Fehler gemacht hatte.
7 oder 8/10 Sek., schätzungsweise.
Und ich wusste,
dass Mair noch oben war.
Der war auch sehr schnell.
(Mann) Michael Mair ist gestartet.
Bestzeit kurz vor dem Cry d'Er.
Da hat ihm sein Gewicht geholfen.
Oh, Sturz!
(Mann)
Jetzt stürzt Michael Mair beinahe.
Das ist natürlich
das Ende seines Rennens.
(Durchsage) Meine Damen und Herren,
das Abfahrtsrennen ist beendigt.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
the men's downhill is finished.
* Getragene, triumphale Musik *
Im ersten Teil war ich gut.
Am Cry d'Er
sprang ich dann aus der Piste,
zu hoch und zu weit.
Da dachte ich schon:
"Jetzt wird es nichts mehr."
Unten fuhr ich dann auf Risiko.
Verrückt.
Ich achtete nicht auf eine Linie,
sondern wollte einfach nur
den kürzesten Weg nehmen,
um nicht wieder Zweiter zu werden.
Ja.
Und sein Sieg war überwältigend.
Ein grosser Moment der Freude,
ich würde sogar sagen
der Erlösung für Pitsch,
der einen solchen Sieg
verdient hatte.
* Getragene, triumphale Musik *
Die Gefühle kommen wieder hoch.
Das muss man herausschneiden.
Das war aussergewöhnlich.
Es war ...
... sein Herzenswunsch.
Er sehnte sich so
nach dieser Goldmedaille.
(Durchsage) Goldmedaille ...
* Lauter Jubel *
Silver medal:
Pirmin Zurbriggen.
(Mann) Im Sport beginnen wir mit
dem Triumph des Herrenabfahrtsteams,
das die Königsdisziplin dieser
Alpinen Skiweltmeisterschaften
in Crans-Montana
buchstäblich dominiert hat.
* Dunkler Klang *
(Mann) Guten Tag,
meine Damen und Herren.
Ein wichtiger Tag
heute in Crans-Montana,
denn in Kürze werden wir hier
die Damenabfahrt sehen.
Es herrscht
eine fantastische Atmosphäre.
Natürlich träumen alle
von einer weiteren Goldmedaille
für das Schweizer Team,
das einen wirklich grossartigen
WM-Auftakt hingelegt hat.
Im Bild sehen wir
die überragende Favoritin,
die amtierende Weltmeisterin
Michela Figini im Startbereich.
Hier eine weitere grosse Favoritin,
Maria Walliser,
die im Training
die Bestzeit erzielt hat.
Wir dürften heute also Zeugen
eines Schweizer Duells werden.
Im Sport hätten sich die beiden
auf gut Deutsch Gift geben können.
Diese Rivalität
bestand praktisch vom ersten Tag an.
* Spannende Musik *
(Mann) Michela Figini am Start.
Die Tessinerin ist gestern
eine Bombenzeit gefahren.
Maria Walliser am Start.
Die grosse Favoritin
ist vielleicht die grösste
Konkurrentin für Michela Figini.
Wir haben die erste Zwischenzeit:
22:34, das ist bisher die schnellste.
22:20, beste Zwischenzeit
für Maria Walliser.
Das wird sehr knapp.
Nein, Maria Walliser
erreicht den zweiten Platz,
5/100 Sek. hinter Figini.
Die Tessinerin
landet einen grossen Coup.
(Mann) Der jungen Tessinerin
gelingt ein sensationeller Einstand
auf der internationalen Bühne.
Jetzt hat sie allen Grund, zu jubeln.
Ich war sozusagen
in letzter Minute dazugekommen.
Für Maria war es wahrscheinlich
sehr hart, mich gewinnen zu sehen,
denn die Favoritin war sie.
Es war sicher hart,
mit nur 5/100 Sek. Zweite zu werden.
Das ist hart, ja.
Damit findet man sich
nicht leicht ab.
5/100, das ist fast nichts.
5/100 Sek. vom Olympiasieg entfernt,
du bist Zweite.
Über den zweiten Platz
spricht niemand,
immer nur über den ersten.
Das ist hart.
(Durchsage) Silbermedaille
für Maria Walliser, Schweiz.
(Keel) Wir mussten sie
fast überreden,
an die Siegerehrung zu gehen,
so enttäuscht war sie,
weil sie es nicht geschafft hatte.
1984 hatte sie nicht gewonnen,
1985 hatte sie nicht gewonnen.
Walliser litt innerlich
sehr darunter,
immer Figini hinterherzufahren.
Ich glaube, die Medien suchten die
Rivalität zwischen Michela und mir.
Sie machten jedes Mal
eine Story draus,
wenn die eine
oder die andere vorne war,
oder wenn eine
schneller war als die andere.
Es ist wahr:
Wenn zwei Schweizerinnen
auf höchstem Niveau
gegeneinander antreten,
konstruieren die Journalisten daraus
schnell eine Rivalität.
Sie waren klug genug,
niemandem zu zeigen,
dass zwischen ihnen
eine grosse Rivalität herrschte,
doch sie war da.
Wenn Michi 14 Liegestütze machte,
machte die andere 15.
Wenn sie vier Abfahrten
trainiert hatten,
ging eine von beiden -
egal, welche -
noch einmal hoch und fuhr eine mehr.
Dieses Duell
trieb diese beiden Frauen
zu absoluten Höchstleistungen an.
Das führte letzten Endes zu diesen
grossen Erfolgen dieser Mannschaft.
Ich muss zugeben, mit Michela
im Team fragte ich mich immer:
"Fokussiere ich mich auf mich selbst
oder schaue ich auch,
was die anderen machen?"
Diese Prozesse waren nicht einfach,
aber ich merkte,
dass ich
meine Leistung abrufen konnte,
wenn ich mich
auf mich selbst konzentrierte.
* Dunkler Klang *
(Mann) Nun ist Michela Figini
an der Reihe ...
... die amtierende Weltmeisterin
und Olympiasiegerin -
die jüngste der Geschichte.
Hier ist sie langsam.
Sie dürfte das Rennen
gegen Ende für sich entscheiden.
Sie geht in Führung. Super, Michi.
(Mann) In dieser Traverse
hat sie sich
eine unglaubliche Reserve geholt.
Michi fährt vielleicht
dem Sieg entgegen.
Fantastische Stimmung im Zielgelände.
Das dürfte eine neue Bestzeit
geben - 1:44:86 gilt es zu schlagen.
75/100 Sek. Vorsprung.
- Sie geht in Führung.
Ein hervorragendes Rennen
von Michela Figini.
Diese Marke gilt es zu schlagen.
Ihre ersten Eindrücke?
Ich bin zufrieden, aber
ich weiss nicht, ob es reichen wird.
Viele sind ja noch nicht gestartet.
(Mann) Es ist noch alles offen.
Wir warten auf Marina Kiehl
und Maria Walliser.
Und jetzt aufgepasst
auf die Deutsche Marina Kiehl.
Sie liegt vorn.
Was für ein super Rennen.
Wir erleben heute
einen grossartigen Tag.
Die Spannung steigt.
Und sie schafft es nicht.
Sie ist Dritte und das Publikum tobt.
Aber jetzt kommt die nächste
grosse Favoritin in der Abfahrt:
Maria Walliser.
* Hämmernde, spannende Musik *
Oh, jetzt ist sie weg.
(Mann) Maria Walliser - Daumen
drücken für die Toggenburgerin.
(Mann) Das ist Bestzeit.
- Sie hat 9/100 Sek. Vorsprung.
Aber jetzt kommt das Stück,
in dem Figini so blendend fuhr.
Die St. Gallerin
liegt immer noch vorn.
Sie hat 35/100 Sek. Vorsprung
auf Michela Figini.
Sie schafft es.
Nein, sie schafft es.
Das wird nun
unwahrscheinlich spannend.
Maria Walliser oder Michela Figini,
das ist im Moment die Frage.
Oh, leichte Schwierigkeiten,
doch sie dürfte ganz nah
an Michela Figini herankommen.
Aber Achtung, das wird sehr eng.
Ja.
1:42:80 - sie geht in Führung.
Heute also ein Sieg für Maria
Walliser, die in Jubel ausbricht.
Maria Walliser vor Michela Figini.
31/100 Sek. vor Michela Figini,
ein weiterer Medaillenregen
für die Schweiz.
* Gefühlvolle, langsame Musik *
Super, Michi. Ein zweiter Platz.
Was für ein Kopf-an-Kopf-Rennen
zwischen den Stärksten der Welt.
Ja, ich bin zufrieden.
Klar, den ersten Platz
hätte ich noch lieber.
Ich hoffte darauf, ich wollte ihn,
aber ich habe es nicht geschafft.
(Walliser) Ich kann nicht
in sie hineinsehen,
um zu sehen,
ob es für sie extrem hart war,
Zweite zu werden.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass sie mit dem zweiten Platz
recht zufrieden war.
* Stimmengewirr *
In Crans-Montana
wollte ich gewinnen.
Ich holte die Silbermedaille,
sehr gut, aber ich wollte gewinnen.
Ob nun Maria vor mir lag oder eine
Sportlerin aus einem anderen Land,
das war egal.
Die Enttäuschung
wäre genauso gross gewesen.
Wirklich?
- Ja, wirklich.
Hast du dich ein bisschen
für sie gefreut oder gar nicht?
Alors ...
Ach, was für eine blöde Frage.
Nein, es ist eine gute Frage.
* Sie lachen. *
Ich könnte sagen:
"Klar habe ich mich für sie gefreut,
aber nicht für mich."
An diesem Tag musste ich mich
fragen, wo ich Gold verloren hatte,
und nicht,
wo ich Silber gewonnen hatte.
Aber doch,
ich konnte Maria gratulieren.
Sie war besser als ich.
(Zurbriggen)
Sie nannten mich immer Mr Super-G.
Das will was heissen.
So ging ich in dieses Rennen -
mit dieser Stärke.
Ich sagte: "Pirmin,
du bist Mr Super-G. Let's go."
(Mann) 54:29 für Girardelli.
Zurbriggen
könnte eigentlich besser fahren.
Ja, er ist besser.
Pirmin Zurbriggen ist durchaus
in der Lage, Girardelli zu schlagen.
"Das muss ein Podestplatz sein,
sonst geht es mir schlecht."
Das ist so gut wie gelaufen.
Achtung, ja. Bravo, Pirmin.
- (Mann) 1:19:93.
(Mann) Jetzt kommt Maria Walliser,
die uns heute Morgen anvertraut hat,
dass sie voll auf Risiko fahren will.
Und das Risiko zahlt sich aus.
Die Stimmung unter uns Landsleuten
vor Ort war hervorragend.
3'000 Menschen standen auf
einem Dach gegenüber der Eisbahn -
ohne Geländer in 50 m Höhe.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich mit dem Auto
dort vorbeifahre
und dieses Dach sehe, habe ich
wieder dieses Bild vor Augen.
(Mann) Heute war wieder ein grosser
Tag für den Schweizer Skisport.
Diese Weltmeisterschaften
entpuppen sich geradezu
als eine Schweizermeisterschaft
mit Teilnahme einiger Ausländer.
* Fliessende, triumphale Musik *
Für mich ist es nicht spannend.
Nur die Schweizer holen Medaillen.
* Dunkler Klang *
(Mann) Guten Tag,
meine Damen und Herren.
Wir befinden uns am Ende der Piste
Chetzeron in Crans-Montana,
wo wir heute den Riesenslalom
der Herren erleben werden.
Unter den Favoriten
sind Namen wie Joël Gaspoz,
der einzige Westschweizer,
der sich für diese Ski-WM
qualifizieren konnte,
und Pirmin Zurbriggen, der heute
seinen 24. Geburtstag feiert.
Wir verfolgen gewissermassen
ein Heimspiel
zwischen dem Ober-
und dem Unterwallis.
In 10 Min. beginnt der erste Lauf.
Ich empfand Joël gegenüber
kein einziges Mal Neid.
Kein einziges Mal.
Im Gegenteil, ich wollte,
dass der Bessere gewinnt.
Und dann stand ich in Crans-Montana
plötzlich mit ihm am Start
und wusste genau:
entweder du oder ich.
* Dunkler Klang *
Pirmin sagte,
dass er mit anderen Abfahrern
häufig Konflikte wegen Neid hatte.
Mit den Slalomfahrern
hatte er nie Probleme.
Man sah sich bei den Läufen
gegenseitig zu und half einander.
Sobald jemand aus dem Team gewann,
kam eine tolle Stimmung auf.
Alle profitierten davon.
Du schaust auch,
was der andere macht.
Mit dem rechten Auge
schaute ich immer auf Joël.
Er war ja immer vor mir.
Er kam mit 15 oder 16
an einen Weltcup, ich mit 17.
Er war immer etwas früher da.
(Gaspoz) Wenn er jemanden
wie mich sah, der sehr schnell fuhr,
spornte ihn das an.
Und er half mir auch viel
mit seiner Art zu trainieren,
mit seiner Regelmässigkeit.
Ja, Zurbriggen
ist wirklich ein Fall für sich.
In den zehn Jahren,
die wir miteinander zu tun hatten,
gab er nicht 1 Sek. lang auf.
Sogar im Training legte er sich
beim Zieleinlauf hinten auf die Ski,
um Zeit zu gewinnen, auch wenn er
die Ziellinie schon überquert hatte.
(Mann) Und jetzt Joël Gaspoz.
1:21:76, um zu gewinnen.
Noch zwei Tore - tatsächlich,
Joël hat es geschafft.
Er ist unbestrittener Sieger.
Bravo, Joël Gaspoz.
(Mann) Pirmin Zurbriggen
ist nach dem ersten Lauf
99/100 Sek. vor Girardelli.
Zurbriggen
ist noch zwei Tore vor dem Ziel.
Und es reicht.
Pirmin Zurbriggen gewinnt.
(Mann) Er hat diesen Hang mit einer
Wahnsinnsgeschwindigkeit genommen.
Geschafft. Bravo, Joël.
Die ganze Westschweiz
feiert diesen sensationellen Triumph
mit Joël Gaspoz.
(Mann) Während sich am Horizont
die lang erwartete Weltmeisterschaft
von Crans-Montana abzeichnet,
liefern sich die beiden Walliser,
Pirmin Zurbriggen und Joël Gaspoz,
ein spannendes Duell im Weltcup.
Entweder
gewinnt der eine oder der andere.
Beim berühmten
Riesenslalom von Adelboden
siegte gestern der Oberwalliser
mit einem Hauch Vorsprung
vor dem Fahrer aus Morgins.
(Zurbriggen)
Wir verbrachten im Training
so viele Stunden miteinander.
Wir teilten auch andere Momente,
in denen ich sah,
wie jeder kämpft, um seine Leistung
hervorbringen zu können.
Schau, wenn ich von Joël spreche ...
... packt mich das
jedes Mal emotional.
Es packt mich immer sehr tief.
Das kommt daher,
dass ich ohne Joël ...
... nicht erreicht hätte,
was ich erreicht habe.
Das sage ich immer und immer wieder.
(Mann) Und hier ist Joël.
Er startet mit der
für ihn typischen Begeisterung.
Er ist hier zu Hause,
und er ist in Topform.
Man sagt sich, vielleicht unbewusst,
dass er das schafft.
Es wird nicht leicht, aber unter
diesen Bedingungen schafft er das.
Und sein erster Lauf ... Ganz klar.
(Mann) Ja, Joël Gaspoz hat
die technische Passage gut geschafft.
Das ist super.
Er hat es wirklich drauf.
1:17:88 ist die Zeit von Tomba.
Das kann Joël besser.
Und er macht es auch besser.
1:17:22 - sensationell.
Sensationell, Joël Gaspoz.
Ich fuhr gut.
Ich spürte, dass ich
von den Fans getragen wurde.
Dieses Gefühl
hat man ziemlich selten.
In meiner Karriere erlebte ich das
nur zwei- oder dreimal,
aber man spürt es wirklich.
Da passiert irgendetwas.
(Mann) Doch da kommt Pirmin
Zurbriggen schon zum letzten Hang.
1:17:22, das ist für ihn machbar.
Es wird sehr knapp.
Ich glaube nicht ...
Er hat 3/10 Sek. verloren - 1:17:52.
Gaspoz vor Zurbriggen.
Während des ersten und zweiten Laufs
waren wir in einem Chalet.
Wir sassen
in einer Ruhe zusammen da.
Wir assen eine Kleinigkeit.
Da sagte ich zu Joël:
"Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen,
ich glaube,
wenn es einer von uns schafft,
dann du."
"Meine Batterien
sind ziemlich flach."
Und Joël sagte mir
noch vor dem Start:
"Los, Pirmin. Das kannst du auch."
(Mann) Und jetzt der grosse Moment
des zweiten Laufs
mit Pirmin Zurbriggen
im Starthäuschen.
41/100 Sek. Vorsprung vor Girardelli,
3/10 Sek. Rückstand auf Joël Gaspoz.
Es wird sehr knapp
zwischen Zurbriggen und Girardelli,
während Joël Gaspoz noch oben steht.
1:14:93, um zu gewinnen.
Hopp, Pirmin.
Ich glaube, es ist möglich.
Ja, 7/100 Sek.
Die Goldmedaille geht an die Schweiz,
ganz egal, wie Joël Gaspoz fährt.
Als ich ins Ziel kam und sah,
wie die Eins aufleuchtete,
dachte ich: "Wow, okay!"
"Silbermedaille.
Das ist die dritte Silbermedaille."
Als Pirmin ins Ziel fuhr, wollte ich
die Zuschauer nicht hören.
Ich wollte nicht wissen,
ob er gewonnen hatte.
(Vial) Und Joël ist gestartet.
Vielleicht ist er auf dem Weg
zu einer zweiten Goldmedaille
für die Westschweiz nach 27 Jahren.
Oh, die Passage war weniger sauber
als bei Zurbriggen.
3/10 Sek. Vorsprung auf Zurbriggen.
Die eine Hälfte der Walliser feuert
Gaspoz an, die andere Hälfte Pirmin.
Wo stehen wir bei der Zwischenzeit?
Achtung,
Joël ist bei der Übergangsstelle.
41:20. Er hat auf Pirmin Zurbriggen
also 3/10 Sek. aufgeholt.
D.h., rein mathematisch
hat er jetzt 33/100 Sek. Vorsprung,
trotz zwei, drei
wirklich kritischer Momente.
Joël sorgt weiterhin für Spannung,
aber das ist nun mal
der Preis des Sieges.
Wir stehen im Zielgelände - genauer
gesagt, am Rand des Zielgeländes -
und schauen auf den Zielhang.
Ich bin mit einem Kollegen da.
Ich beobachte, wie der Fahrer
das letzte Tor
vor dem Schlussabschnitt passiert,
und mein Kollege Patrick
schaut auf die Zeitanzeige.
Joël Gaspoz
taucht auf dem letzten Hang auf.
1:02, geschafft.
1:03, knapp.
1:04, vorbei.
Und hier kommt Joël.
Ich sehe Joël und rufe: "Go!"
Mein Kollege sagt nur: "1:02",
und es ist alles klar.
Bei 1:02 ist es geschafft.
Nur noch wenige Sekunden.
Ich denke, es reicht.
1:15:16, das ist möglich.
Und der Rennfahrer aus Morgins ...
Nein!
Nein, Joël, vier Tore vor dem Ziel!
* Düstere Musik *
Plötzlich war alles vorbei.
Es war schon ziemlich surreal.
Für mich war dieser Moment
fast eine Katastrophe.
Es war eine Katastrophe, zu sagen:
"Pirmin, du hast die Goldmedaille,
und Joël hat nichts."
Am Mittag hatten wir noch gehofft,
beide würden eine Medaille gewinnen.
* Wehmütige Musik *
Ich konnte mich
in diesem Moment nicht halten.
Ich schob alle zur Seite
und ging Joël entgegen.
Ich bin wirklich stolz auf dich.
* Wehmütige Musik *
So war's eben.
Das ist mein Stil,
ich fahre immer am Limit.
Vielleicht fahre ich deswegen
so gut und schnell.
Und da habe ich vielleicht
etwas zu viel riskiert.
Bevor ich stürzte,
war ich noch sehr schnell,
und wenn ich durchgekommen wäre,
hätte ich sicher gewonnen.
So ist das nun mal.
Es tat mir leid für die Leute, die
gekommen waren, um mich zu sehen.
Und diese Leute
waren meinetwegen traurig.
Als ich all diese Tränen sah,
war es,
als würde mir Liebe geschenkt.
Und so sah ich, dass manche
noch viel trauriger waren als ich,
denn für mich
war es eigentlich okay.
Wenn meine Karriere so gross ist,
wäre sie als Weltmeister
so gross gewesen.
Es war kein Problem,
den Titel nicht zu bekommen.
Für mich war es wie
ein grosser sportlicher Höhepunkt.
Zuerst absolute Stille und dann
ein Schrei von Jacques Deschenaux,
der die Stille durchdringt.
Einfach super.
Irgendwie war es schön.
Für mich
war Joël der Champ, nicht ich.
Das ist ja das Lustige.
Letzten Endes haben wir den Sieg
miteinander errungen.
Ich glaube, es ergibt alles Sinn,
wenn man es richtig anschaut
und richtig packt.
Tu sais pas où tu es.
Hast du verstanden,
was ich gesagt habe?
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Was unter uns als Team zählt,
sind Herz und Wille.
In dieser Hinsicht haben wir,
glaube ich, einen Sieg errungen.
Einen viel grösseren als denjenigen,
den wir der Welt präsentierten
und den er verlor.
Das war unser Sieg, finde ich.
Nicht die Ergebnisse.
Ich glaube,
er hat genau dasselbe gesagt.
Dann haben wir wirklich gewonnen.
(Mann) Jetzt nur keinen Fehler
von Vreni Schneider
in den letzten Toren.
1:11:82 - jawohl,
sie ist Weltmeisterin.
Eine weitere Goldmedaille
für die Schweiz.
Ein Goldrausch und kein Ende: die
siebte Goldmedaille für die Schweiz
dank Vreni Schneider.
Bronze für Maria Walliser.
Sie erlangten einen Sieg nach
dem anderen. Sie gewannen alles.
(Mann) ... um in Führung zu gehen.
Neue Bestzeit.
Erika Hess ist als einzige
Schweizerin noch mit dabei.
Sie wird in ihrem letzten Rennen
Weltmeisterin.
Meine Damen und Herren,
liebe Skifans,
die Stunde des Abschieds
und der Dankesworte ist gekommen.
Diese Veranstaltung
war ein voller Erfolg.
Am letzten Tag,
als die WM zu Ende ging,
heulte ich im Büro
wie ein kleiner Junge.
Wenn man heute
eine Veranstaltung organisiert,
sagt man oft: "Ups, es ist vorbei."
Damals hätte man gerne
weitergemacht.
(Keller) Crans-Montana war auf
jeden Fall der Höhepunkt jener Zeit,
in der wir alles gewannen.
Und ganz klar:
Danach folgte die Leere.
Ich erinnere mich,
dass nach Crans-Montana noch
ein paar Riesenslaloms anstanden.
Der Gesamtweltcup wurde
zwischen Pirmin und mir ausgemacht.
(Mann) Die Zahlen sind klar:
Joël muss auf jeden Fall gewinnen,
wenn er den Riesenslalomweltcup
nochmals für sich entscheiden will.
Das ist
eine sehr gute Leistung für Joël,
der damit in Führung geht.
Heute kann er hier den Sieg erringen.
Alles hängt nun
von Marc Girardellis Leistung ab.
Die Zeit, die es zu schlagen gilt,
ist 1:25:77 - und er schafft es.
Joël Gaspoz ist Zweiter.
Damit übernimmt Girardelli
die Rolle von Pirmin Zurbriggen.
Wir hatten dieselbe Punktzahl,
aber er hatte einen Sieg mehr
und somit
den Gesamtweltcup gewonnen.
Eine herbe Enttäuschung für Joël.
Was hat er Ihnen gesagt?
Nein, wie ich Joël kenne,
nimmt er das sehr sportlich.
Er weiss, wie hart der Sport ist,
und ich glaube,
seine Revanche wird kommen.
(Mann) Joël Gaspoz,
das stumpf gewordene Eisen
unter den Schweizer Technikern,
macht einen Abstecher in die Natur.
(Mann) Einmal mehr wird Joël Gaspoz
vom Unglück verfolgt.
Jacques, was ist los mit Joël?
(Mann) Joël konnte die Erwartungen
an ihn nicht bestätigen.
Er ist nun zum fünften Mal in Folge
ausgeschieden,
sei es beim Slalom
oder beim Riesenslalom.
Man hat auch den Eindruck,
dass Ihr Sturz bei der WM in Crans
eine Art Kurzschluss bewirkt hat.
Ja, sicher habe ich
vor dem Rennen hier daran gedacht,
aber mit den richtigen Ski
hätte ich heute wahrscheinlich
unter den Ersten sein können.
(Zurbriggen) Diese Geschichte
hinterlässt Spuren.
Als ich im nächsten Jahr
zum Training kam, merkte ich,
dass das nicht mehr
der alte Joël war.
Nach dieser Saison beschloss ich,
meine Karriere zu beenden.
(Männer) # Joël, Joël, Joël.
Ganz von selbst wurde eine neue
Seite in meinem Leben aufgeschlagen.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass sich etwas geändert hätte,
wenn ich vorher mehr oder weniger
Rennen gewonnen hätte.
Ich persönlich war mit
dem Erreichten absolut zufrieden.
Und ich war auch sehr froh,
aufzuhören.
(Zurbriggen)
Ich hätte nicht geglaubt,
dass es so weit kommen würde,
dass er total aufgibt.
Warum erlitt Joël dieses Schicksal
und bei mir ging's auf?
Das frage ich mich heute noch.
(Mann) Pirmin Zurbriggen
rast dem Sieg entgegen.
Pirmin Zurbriggen ist Olympiasieger.
Der Erfolg der Schweiz
hat viele Auswirkungen in den USA,
v.a. dank Pirmin Zurbriggen.
Der Skisport
hatte jahrelang keine Superstars -
und Pirmin ist der neue Superstar.
(Mann) Er ist heute weit mehr
als der beste Skifahrer der Welt.
Er ist zugleich unkompliziert
und beim Umgang mit seiner Karriere
und seinem Status doch so geschickt.
Er hat sich zu einem modernen
Wilhelm Tell entwickelt,
in dem sich
fast eine ganze Nation wiederfindet.
Diese enorme Last versucht er immer
mit einem gewissen Abstand zu tragen.
* Schweizerpsalm *
Dir begegnen immer wieder
Journalisten.
Ich glaube, da würde man sich
eine Idealfrage vorstellen.
Was möchten Sie
gerne endlich mal gefragt werden?
Das ist schwer.
Ich wurde schon so vieles gefragt,
dass ich sagen muss:
Am liebsten wäre mir,
du würdest nichts fragen.
Erst kam Bormio, dann Crans-Montana,
dann Calgary, dann wieder eine WM.
Peng, peng, peng, peng, peng.
Das hat so viel
Energie und Kraft gefordert.
Nur noch fokussiert und motiviert -
alles auf ein Ziel gerichtet.
Und das war Erfolg.
Da musste ich sagen: Du hast
ein Problem. Du hast genug erreicht.
Es war wirklich cool. Es war genial.
Weisst du, wie schön es ist,
wenn man on the top aufhören kann?
(Mann) Es ist der krönende Abschluss
seiner Karriere.
Pirmin hat bereits viermal
die grosse Kristallkugel
und viermal die im Super-G gewonnen,
um seine Trophäensammlung
zu vervollständigen.
(Mann) Hier in Crans-Montana
stand ein Mann
ganz im Mittelpunkt
der Aufmerksamkeit.
Es handelt sich um keinen Geringeren
als Pirmin Zurbriggen,
der sich offiziell
von den Wettkämpfen
und von seinen Fans
verabschiedet hat.
Ich bin sehr glücklich,
dass so viele Leute zu meinem
vorletzten Rennen gekommen sind.
Herzlichen Dank an alle, die mich
unterstützt haben, an alle Skifans.
Ja ...
* Vielstimmiges Lachen *
* Musik und Applaus *
(Mann) Noch 10 Min. bis zum
ersten grossen Alpinskirennen
dieser Olympischen Spiele in Calgary:
die Olympia-Abfahrt der Herren.
Peter Müller trägt die Startnummer 1.
Er ist gestartet.
Der letzte Doppelsprung,
der zu bewältigen ist,
mit einer Zeit von 2:00:14.
Jetzt braucht Müller
90 Sek. lang starke Nerven.
(Mann) Peter Müller wartet
auf seinen grössten Konkurrenten.
2:00:14 war Müllers Zeit.
Zurbriggen ist kurz vor dem Ziel.
5/10 Sek. Vorsprung
für Pirmin Zurbriggen.
(Mann) Man sieht das mit einem
weinenden und einem lachenden Auge:
Pirmins Freude
und Peters Enttäuschung.
(Mann) Medaille d'argent:
Peter Müller de la Suisse.
Für Peter Müller ist Crans-Montana
bis jetzt ein goldenes Intermezzo
in einer mit Silbermedaillen
gespickten Karriere.
Gestern wurde er
an den Weltmeisterschaften von Vail,
obwohl er seinen ewigen Rivalen
Zurbriggen endlich losgeworden ist,
wieder Zweiter,
nachdem er diesen Platz bereits
an den Olympischen Spielen,
der Weltmeisterschaft
und in den Abfahrt-Weltcups
von 1984 bis 1988 belegt hatte.
Irgendwann gab man dir den Stempel
des ewigen Zweiten.
Stresste dich das?
Nein,
ich war lieber Zweiter als Dritter.
(Mann) Val Gardena,
13. Dezember 1989.
Plötzlich passiert die Katastrophe.
Ein fürchterlicher Sturz.
(Mann) Was ist los?
- (Müller) Das Knie ist kaputt.
Was?
- Das Knie ist kaputt.
Kreuz- und Innenband gerissen
und dazu beide Menisken -
für Peter Müller
war die Saison zu Ende,
bevor sie begonnen hatte.
Das musste wieder sein,
verdammt noch mal.
* Düstere Musik *
(Mann) Peter Müller -
ein Mann, der niemals aufgibt.
Trotz seiner 33 Jahre
und seiner Knieverletzung,
die ihn über ein Jahr
vom Skifahren abhielt,
ist der alte Zürcher Löwe
zurück im Skizirkus.
Sein Ziel: an die Spitze
zurückzukehren und das Gold zu holen,
das er seit so vielen Jahren
verpasst hat.
Sechster bei der Zwischenzeit,
das entspricht leider
nicht den Erwartungen.
Mit dem Knie war es nicht mehr
möglich, schnell Ski zu fahren.
Ich konnte es
nicht mehr als 90 % biegen.
Ich fuhr noch zwei Jahre lang
therapiemässig mit,
aber ich habe ...
Es fehlte einfach etwas.
Ich wusste am Start, bei einem
optimalen Lauf würde ich 15. werden,
bei einem schlechten 30.
Wenn ich richtig verstehe,
hast du zwei Jahre gebraucht,
um zu akzeptieren,
dass du dein Topniveau
nicht mehr erreichen konntest.
So ist es.
Im Sport verabschieden wir uns heute
von einem Skifahrer,
mit dem wir oft gezittert haben
und der heute in Aspen in den USA
zu seinem letzten Abfahrtsrennen
angetreten ist.
(Mann) Zum 139. und letzten Mal
ist Peter Müller
am Start einer Weltcup-Abfahrt.
Und zum letzten Mal
hat er die Ziellinie überquert -
19. mit 2,09 Sek. Abstand auf Mahre.
Wenn er zurückblickt auf das,
was er erreicht hat,
schaut Pitsch
auf einen Riesenberg von Erfolgen.
(Mann) Es liegt einige Jahre zurück,
dass ihr Duell an der Spitze
die Gemüter erregte.
Seit 1984 und
den Olympischen Spielen von Sarajevo
haben Michela Figini
und Maria Walliser
alle möglichen Abfahrtstrophäen
untereinander aufgeteilt.
Die Weltmeisterschaften, die heute
in Vail, Colorado, eröffnet werden,
sind keine Ausnahme von der
seit fünf Jahren geltenden Regel.
Die beiden Meisterinnen
der Geschwindigkeit
werden auch hier als
die grossen Favoritinnen gehandelt.
(Mann) Hervorragend - Maria Walliser
kommt gleich ins Ziel
und könnte ihren Exploit
von Crans-Montana wiederholen.
1:46:50 -
Weltmeisterin
Maria Walliser im Freudentaumel.
(Frau) Die Tessinerin Michela Figini,
momentan die unbestrittene
Weltcup-Leaderin,
hat bei der WM in Vail heute Morgen
nur den 8. Platz erreicht.
Mit einem komfortablen Vorsprung
hat ihre Konkurrentin und Team-
kollegin Maria Walliser gewonnen,
die sich bereits vor zwei Jahren
in Crans-Montana den Titel sicherte.
Crans war mit drei Medaillen
zwar schön,
aber wenn du mich nach meinem
absoluten Lieblingsrennen fragst,
dann ist es dasjenige 1989 in Vail.
Dort war ich fast auf Wolke 7,
von Anfang an.
(Mann) Goldmedaille,
Abfahrt der Damen 1989:
Maria Walliser, Schweiz.
Ich war 27.
Ich war zehn Jahre lang auf höchstem
Niveau an Weltcups dabei gewesen.
Der Kreis hatte sich
komplett geschlossen,
und ich war einfach
dankbar für alles.
(Frau) Nur zwei Monate nach ihrer
grossen Rivalin Maria Walliser
hat auch Michela Figini beschlossen,
dem Profisport den Rücken zu kehren.
Mit nur 24 Jahren verlässt sie
die Wettkampfarena abrupt
nach einem unlösbaren Konflikt
mit dem Schweizerischen Skiverband
und dem Cheftrainer
der Abfahrerinnen, Jan Tischhauser.
Sie war vielleicht
die Erste ihrer Zeit,
die ihr privates Team
aufstellen wollte.
Heute ist das gang und gäbe.
Damals wollte es
das Schweizer Team aber nicht.
(Mann)
Mit 24 auszusteigen, ist sehr früh.
Ja, es ist früh.
Ich weiss, ich könnte noch
gute Ergebnisse erzielen,
aber nur, wenn die Motivation
und der Wille stimmen.
Du musst den Leuten,
die dich coachen, vertrauen können -
v.a. der einen Person,
die dich coacht.
(Keller) Wir sprechen von 1990,
also vor 30 Jahren.
Da waren die Verbände
sehr unnachgiebig,
das war einfach so - und nur so.
Es gab einen heftigen Wortwechsel
und Michi stellte die Forderung:
"Entweder du oder ich."
Tischhauser konnte man damals
wirklich schwerlich abschiessen,
denn er hatte einfach
gnadenlosen Erfolg.
Von 34 Rennen
hatten seine Mädchen 29 gewonnen.
Sie war im Unrecht,
und man konnte sie nicht mehr
davon abbringen, aufzuhören.
Schluss, aus, Amen.
Für mich ist es einfach unmöglich,
einen grauen Mittelweg zu finden.
Entweder weiss oder schwarz.
Und wenn ich eine Entscheidung
treffe, bleibt es dabei.
Ich sehe meine Tätigkeit v.a.
im Bereich Werbung, Kommunikation.
Die Sympathien, die ich im alpinen
Skirennsport erobern konnte,
will ich in irgendeiner anderen Form
weitergeben können.
Ich hatte natürlich
schon während meiner Karriere
die Fühler ausgestreckt -
ich stand mit Sponsoren,
Managern usw. im Kontakt.
* Langsame, sphärische Musik *
(Keel) Das hat ihrem Leben sicher
auch eine andere Wendung gegeben.
Sie hätte ja jede Chance gehabt.
Sie hätte in der Schweiz
alles machen können.
Sie hätte die Möglichkeit gehabt,
viel stärker
in der Öffentlichkeit zu bleiben.
Im Sport kanalisierte man das,
was für einen wichtig war.
Als ich dann eine Familie hatte,
spürte ich das nicht mehr.
Es ging nicht nur um meine Person,
meine Leistung und meinen Erfolg.
Ich musste viel weicher werden,
viel weniger egoistisch.
Ich musste lernen,
vor- und nachzugeben.
Gerade im Zusammenhang
mit unserer ersten Tochter
ist mir das sehr zugute gekommen.
* Langsame, sphärische Musik *
(Figini) Ich widmete mich
ganz meiner Familie.
Wie ich heute lebe,
ist für mich das wahre Leben.
Zuvor war es ein Traum,
ein Intermezzo.
Eine wichtige Zeit zwar, doch
mit einem Anfang und einem Ende.
Das wahre Leben
geht dagegen immer weiter.
(Müller) Ich probierte einiges -
einiges ging in die Hose,
einiges gelang.
Ich dachte dann:
"Du kannst einen anderen Job ausüben
und hast die gleiche Freude,
die gleiche Faszination,
die gleichen Gefühle
wie beim Skifahren."
Das war natürlich
ein ziemlicher Trugschluss.
* Langsame, sphärische Musik *
Im Spitzensport bist du entweder
an der Decke oder im Keller.
Das normale Leben findet mehr
im mittleren Bereich statt.
Die grossen Emotionen erlebst
du dort weniger - oder anders.
* Getragene, gefühlvolle Musik *
Etwa zwei Drittel meines Lebens
sind vorbei.
Jetzt versuche ich,
ein Drittel noch zu geniessen
oder das zu tun,
was mir Spass und Freude macht.
Ich muss sagen, dass mir
mein Leben als Sportlerin
bei allem geholfen hat,
auch heute noch.
Natürlich machen einen
die Siege euphorisch,
aber eigentlich
sind es die Niederlagen,
die deinen Charakter
wirklich formen.
* Getragene, gefühlvolle Musik *
(Gaspoz) Ich würde sagen, dass ich
nur dank meiner Vergangenheit
heute so bin, wie ich bin.
Der Spitzensport war für mich
ein ideales Sprungbrett,
das mir ermöglicht hat,
mich selbst besser kennenzulernen.
Ich habe mir das nicht ausgesucht.
Ich weiss nicht einmal,
ob man es sich aussuchen kann.
Es ist einfach so passiert,
und alles ist perfekt so.
* Getragene, gefühlvolle Musik *
(Walliser) Eine Skikarriere,
wie ich sie erleben durfte,
begleitet einen immer.
Es ist natürlich
eine Momentaufnahme.
Es war einige Jahre lang aktuell.
Aber man kann es nicht abstreifen.
Das begleitet einen wohl,
bis man stirbt.
(Zurbriggen) Manchmal heute noch.
Ich träume nachts, dass ich
am Start eines Rennens stehe.
Und dann merke ich:
"Hey, Pirmin, das ist nicht real."
Dann fange ich
richtig an zu schwitzen.
Aber du siehst,
wie tief die Emotionen waren.
30 Jahre später ...
... hast du Träume, in denen du
die Kollegen am Start siehst:
"Hey, was machen die hier?"
"Jetzt sind wir wieder am Start."
Da weiss man, wie tief das war.
* Gefühlvoller Popsong:
"Forever Young" von Alphaville *
# Let's dance in style,
let's dance for a while.
# Heaven can wait,
we're only watching the skies,
# hoping for the best,
but expecting the worst.
# Are you gonna drop the bomb or not?
# Let us die young
or let us live forever.
# We don't have the power,
but we never say never.
# Sitting in a sand pit,
live is a short trip.
# The music's for the sad man.
# Can you imagine
when this race is won?
# Turn our golden faces into the sun.
# Praising our leaders,
we're getting in tune.
# The music's played
by the, the madman.
# Forever young -
I want to be forever young.
# Do you really want to live forever,
forever and ever?
# Forever young -
I want to be forever young.
# Do you really want to live forever?
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Daniel McMinn - 2021